this is my iPhone 15 Pro Max now I've
been using it over the past 2 weeks and
recently really thinking about which of
the top new features have actually
mattered to me personally in the real
world which ones have I actually used
and which ones have I not like actually
the action button which turns out I
haven't really been using it that much
but that's just me so in this video I'm
going to focus on the top five new
features that I've actually been really
using and loving and it includes one of
them that Apple didn't even really focus
on during their announcement so let's
get into feature number one which is
actually the 5x Tetra prism camera I've
just realized that I have literally been
obsessed with this new 5x camera
particularly with portrait shots they
just look absolutely abolutely insane
very natural and unlike any other
portraits I've seen from any other
smartphone these actually look like they
came out of a pro DSLR camera and I love
the way that the new smart HDR 5 works
together with the 5x lens to make the
portraits look very good and natural we
just got back from this awesome weekend
getaway with our friends at this really
cool castle Airbnb and I noticed myself
taking so many 5X portraits specifically
like this one with the kind of Sunshine
from the window just making this awesome
awesome effect just looks incredible and
natural we even had this one that we
took on the top of the mountain which
was an insanely hard situation because
to my eyes all of the faces were black
because it was just so bright but the
smart HDR 5 kind of brought it up to
make it still look good and noticeable
now it's not the best shot but for the
situation it was absolutely abolutely
great so this new 5x camera is giving us
portraits that look like nothing else
that we've seen before looking like a
pro camera and I think I'm actually
going to grab my A7
r4a Pro Camera which is very very
expensive and do a shootout between that
and this at 120 mm focal length which is
5X we'll see how it goes but out of all
the new features this 5x camera is the
one that I've actually used and loved
the most now getting into new feature
number two that I've actually been
loving we have USB type c but before I
get into that I've got to show you
something that's been life-changing for
me now that summer is coming to a close
this is the brand new Soho sneaker from
her partner vessie which is 100%
waterproof using their unique Diamond
Tex material being their first sneaker
with a synthetic leather exterior that's
incredibly stylish and comfortable and
the other day day it literally saved my
socks from getting wet when we had to go
out and film b-roll for our iPhone 15
Pro review in the rain with a bunch of
puddles everywhere and thankfully I
didn't forget my matching vessie
overcast jacket which is also 100%
waterproof repelling water like it's
nothing while being incredibly
comfortable with a relaxed fit design
soft fleece lining and even zipper
Pockets to keep your things secure and
dry together they're the perfect match
for wet weather and of course style they
come in a variety of trendy colors and
you can order them today by using the
link below to get 15% off your order
with the code maxtech at checkout this
is working so much better than I ever
imagined it would when Apple announced
it basically everything supports it all
of my cables now work to charge the
iPhone in a bunch of other accessories
that I have in my house I actually used
the same cable to charge my iPhone and
then I instantly switched it to charge
my portable speaker which was so nice
and convenient I have this awesome
charge key accessory from Nomad which is
basically a short kind of magnetic
accessory that's actually a small little
USBC to see cable and now I have this on
me at all times with my keys whenever I
need it which is really really cool and
I've actually already used it so this
has been very nice to have to my
surprise it even puts out a good amount
power I believe 4.5 Watts so I can
actually power things like this phone
cooler from Razer that I used a bunch of
times for testing to try to test out the
overheating see if I can stop the basic
thermal throttling or heat soaking of
the iPhone chassis so it's just so cool
the things that you can plug in I even
use USBC to transfer a ton of video
clips that I recorded on my iPhone 15
Pro Max for a dedicated sponsored review
and all of the clips transferred in
seconds it was crazy it was just about
the time that it used to take to
transfer the same amount of photos but
they're actually nice cinematic videos
we tested so many USBC hubs devices and
everything works multiple SD cards we
even saw people connecting keyboards and
playing certain games with
WD on the keyboard I also used an
adapter to connect my projector with 4K
60fps quality which is only possible now
thanks to USBC giving me an awesome
gaming experience and I can't wait to
play those AAA ported games and speaking
of gaming we have the A7 Pro chip which
is feature number three now honestly
when the initial reviews and reports
came out with the chip just taken a ton
of Power with issues with all the
overheating that was happening I was
convinced that this chip was a major
disappointing flop however after Apple's
overheating update it's actually been
performing so well for so many other
people including myself Apple actually
fixed it on top of that I've also
noticed the battery life has gotten so
much better my second week of owning the
15 Pro Max compared to the first and
especially after the overheating update
the battery life is finally really
really good I actually made a video that
talked about how to get rid of
overheating during gaming using the
Razer phone cooler but to my surprise my
iPhone 15 Pro Max was killing it with
consistent FPS and the display actually
didn't dim down at all after 30 minutes
of playing genin impact at 100% display
brightness and yes metal effects
upscaling was off I tested other games
like cod mobile and Pascal's wager as
well no dimming at all now one reason
for that could be because we have
another GPU core four now up to six of
them so basically the graphics load is
split up between all of them which now
allows the overall clock speed to run
slower on each core which leads to a lot
less heat during gaming so overall I'm
very surprised and impressed by the A7
Pro chip and I really want to play those
AAA games and now for number four we
have the 24 megapixel default camera
mode along with all the other software
optimizations that came with that I'm
absolutely loving the new 24 megapixel
default output because For the First
Time in so many years we finally got an
upgrade from The Standard 12 megapixels
that apple and so many other brands have
stuck to for so long the difference is
actually noticeable especially when you
zoom in just a little bit and compare it
to regular 12 megapixel mode from the
previous iPhone 14 pro and other
smartphone Brands like the s23 ultra and
I absolutely love the fact that the 1X
camera portraits are also now taken at
24 megapixels my wife has been taking 1X
portraits on her 15 Pro especially at
camp and of kids and the difference has
been noticeable with overall sharper and
more detailed looking photos they just
look great this basically sets Apple
apart from the rest of the smartphone
World especially since apple is allowing
full software functionality and support
at 24 megapixels which some people might
not realize is actually a huge deal
because it takes a lot more processing
power to be able to take these photos
compared to 12 megapixels even like
enabling the live photos and 24
megapixel output at the same time that
is really tough on the processing and
apple makes it work flawlessly and I
know for sure the rest of the industry
is going to follow in Apple's footsteps
with setting 24 megapixels as the new
default Vol which shows just how big of
a deal this is and for feature number
five we have something that Apple didn't
really talk about much at all I've been
experiencing noticeably better cellular
service with the 15 Pro Max and on top
of that less overheating while using 5G
or location services it's just more
efficient as well now this one is a bit
of a phantom feature because Apple
didn't really focus on it but the new
15s now come with the Snapdragon x70
modem which is faster and more efficient
leading to less heat now when we just
got the phone and we tested it in our
office we noticed a huge difference in
the cellular speeds especially here in
our concrete office building that
actually matters a lot because when it
comes to Cellular issues the main
problems that come in are in certain
areas or buildings where you just
wouldn't get a good signal or maybe no
signal at all for example at our
campgrounds that we camp at during the
the summer we used to have a bunch of
connectivity issues with T-Mobile having
really slow service that was just barely
good enough to load emails or some
Twitter posts but my wife was there
recently with her new 15 Pro and she
said it's been getting noticeably better
she even said that with her previous 14
pro she wouldn't even be able to
initiate a phone call at all with the
call instantly ending as soon as she hit
the call button with no ringing or
anything like that but with the new 15
Pro it actually initiates it calls it
rings she can get on a call with
somebody using LTE now that right there
is progress and that's a massive deal
when it comes to the real world use of
your phone so Bravo qualcom for this
great Moto so there you guys go those
were my top five features that I've
loved and used the most over the past
couple of weeks on my 15 Pro Max let me
know your favorite down below subscribe
above definitely check out one of those
two videos right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
[Music]
video